يتركز القتال في العاصمه بمدنها الثلاث
قصف بالمدفعيه الثقيله في منطقه الفتحاب
جنوبيه ام درمان اشتباكات مسلحه شمالها
الخرطوم بحري لكن الاشتباكات الانف تركزت
في مدينه الخرطوم تحديدا محيط القصر
الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه يتبادل طرفها القتال الاتهامات
بشان خرق الهدنه يقول الجيش السوداني ان
الدعم السريع واصل محاولات الهجوم على مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في محيط
المطار بينما قالت قوه الدعم السريع ان
الجيش هاجما بالمدفعيه والطيران الحربي
مواقع تمركز الدعم السريع في القصر
الجمهوري في محيط العاصمه تتواصل
الامدادات العسكريه لكلا الطرفين تتوافد
تعزيزات الجيش قادمه من المناطق الشماليه
في العاصمه باتجاه الاحياء الجنوبيه في
الخرطوم بحري وام درمان يتواصل وامدادات
قوات الدعم السريع قادمه من المناطق
الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من البلاد وتلك
مناطق تعتبر نقاط ارتكاز للدعم السريع كل
هذه الاشتباكات اسفرت وفق وزاره الصحه
السودانيه عن مقتل اكثر من 50012 سودانيا
وجرح الالاف بينما تتواصل عمليات اجلاء
الاجانب الى بلدانهم عبر مدينه بورتسودان
بمطارها وميناءها شرقيا البلاد
[موسيقى]